- OK, welcome to the second
of our lectures in the Ocean
Lecture Series
here at Radcliffe.
So just for those
of you for new here,
we have a theme for the science
portion of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced
Study this year,
which is on oceans and
various aspects of oceans.
Our first lecture
in the series was
about adapting to
hurricane risks.
We had a science
symposium, which
was talking about the
origins of life in the oceans
and also the role
that the oceans
play in climate
and the pressures
that we are putting
on the ocean.
So today we have two speakers,
from the local Boston
sector in District One
from the Coast Guard,
to talk about two particular
aspects of the Coast Guard's
missions but let me give
you some background.
I teach a course at
Harvard in navigation,
which came as a result
of a kayak accident
that I was in
close proximity to.
And a book emerged from that.
One of the members of the Coast
Guard from the Boston sector
approached me and
asked me to give a talk
to the officers about that.
And we started to form
something of a loose relation
and discussion, in part
because I'm a sea kayaker.
We carry around little
VHF transceivers
and listen to the Coast Guard
and listen to their advice
about how to stay
alive out there.
And recently I was given a tour
of their facilities in Boston.
About two years ago, we had a
science symposium on navigation
where we had an expert on
land-based search and rescues.
And I've always been
curious about how
search and rescues
are done near shore
waters and offshore waters.
And so that was
one of the themes
that I was hoping to
explore a bit here.
And the other theme has
to do with the stresses
that we humans are
putting on the oceans.
We seem to sometimes think of
it as an infinite resource,
but on the other
hand it's really
turning into a very
finite resource in terms
of the fisheries, the amount
of plastics in the ocean,
this kind of thing.
And the Coast Guard
is on the front lines
of trying to protect
that resource locally.
So I wanted to explore
both of these items
in a talk which we're
going to be splitting.
So we have here today
Captain Claudia Gelzer, who
will be talking about the
environmental protection
aspect, and Commander
Lee Titus, who
will be talking about the
search and rescue aspect.
So without any
further ado, Claudia,
can you introduce the topic?
Thank you.
- Well, thank you so
much, Professor Huth.
It's really truly an honor
to be here with you tonight.
And I'm in awe of
everyone coming out.
It's a very Coast
Guard night for you
to come out and thank you
for weathering the storm.
We feel at home in this weather.
As you heard, I'm
Claudia Gelzer.
I am the local Operational
Commander for the Coast Guard
in Boston and Massachusetts.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Lee Titus.
And we're really grateful
to the Radcliffe Institute
and Professor Huth
for including us
in this important
discussion on the health
and protection of our oceans.
The Coast Guard has a
huge interest and stake
in many of the issues that have
been explored over the past,
or for the next
couple months that
are going on, and certainly
at the Ocean Symposium.
And I thought it
would be good if I
could begin with some broad
context just about the Coast
Guard.
Which I feel is-- we're
right in your backyard,
and yet I still feel
we're a service that's
a bit mysterious to some.
And so it all began in 1790
as a vision of our founder
and one of the nation's
founding fathers.
He's someone who
is finally getting
some of the
well-deserved recognition
in the musical
Hamilton, although some
say it's overrated.
Alexander Hamilton proposed the
precursor to the Coast Guard,
saying a few armed
vessels, judiciously
stationed at the
entrances of our ports,
might at a small expense be
useful sentinels of the law.
And that is how it began with
the Revenue Cutter Service,
comprised of just 10 ships
keeping watch along the East
Coast to enforce tariff laws.
From those days, our service
has evolved enormously.
Created by fusing the Revenue
Cutter Service, the Lifesaving
Service, the Lighthouse Service,
the Bureau of Navigation,
and the Steamboat
Inspection Service
to officially form what was
called, starting in 1940,
the United States Coast Guard.
And just like the Revenue
Cutter Service, to this day
we stand guard in
our ports executing
a variety of maritime
missions that
uphold safety, security,
and environmental protection
at sea.
And I would argue-- still at
a relatively small expense.
So this is kind of depicting
the variety of missions.
And really I've kind
of divided into when
we're protecting
people from the ocean
and when we are trying to
protect the ocean from people.
So again, you know privileged
to be part of this Ocean Lecture
series.
Your Coast Guard is usually
invested in activities at sea,
but I want to stress that
those activities span well
beyond the oceans.
While we have a considerable
presence on the East, West,
and Gulf Coast, we also
protect the Great Lakes,
the mighty inland rivers,
and waters in US territories.
And for the first time,
we're encountering new oceans
as melting ice opens
up the Arctic region.
The Coast Guard is unique,
as it is simultaneously
a military force and a federal
law enforcement agency.
No other DOD service
can claim that.
We protect and defend more than
100,000 miles of US coastline
and navigable
rivers and safeguard
the largest exclusive economic
zone in the world, a zone
200 nautical miles out to
sea, 4.5 million square miles
stretching from north
of the Arctic Circle
to south of the equator,
from Puerto Rico
to Guam, encompassing
nine time zones--
all with a force about the size
of the New York City Police
Department.
The Coast Guard numbers
just about 56,000,
including our civilian force.
We're a fraction of the size
of any other DOD service,
living on a budget of
about $10 billion a year.
That's just under
the price of one
naval aircraft carrier
battle group, not
a bad value to the taxpayer.
The fifth armed service
and only military branch
in the Department of Homeland
Security, the Coast Guard
has served in every
war in US history.
Moreover, the Coast Guard
is a first responder
and humanitarian service.
We render aid to people
in trouble at sea
or impacted by man
and natural disasters.
The Coast Guard also inspects
all commercial vessels
for safety.
We investigate accidents on
ships operating in our waters,
as well as on any US
vessel operating anywhere
in the world.
We have a presence in
Europe and the Far East,
conducting international port
security assessments, all
of this to ensure the integrity
of our maritime transportation
system.
Right here in
Massachusetts, there
are about 1,200
Coast Guard members
manning shore
units that regulate
industry, mark channels
with aids and navigation,
working on patrol boats,
search and rescue stations,
and at an air
station on Cape Cod.
By law, the Coast Guard's
responsible for 11
distinct maritime missions.
But without running down
that list, which I find.
People tend to forget,
I'll quote a politician
who captured the breath
of our responsibilities
when he said, quote,
"the Coast Guard is
Congress's favorite manservant
for every problem that's wet".
While conducting
law enforcement,
rescue and regulatory
activities,
one underlying focus prevails--
the Coast Guard's duty
to facilitate maritime
commerce and protect
the vital maritime
transportation system.
That system moves critical
cargoes to our waters.
Here in Boston that
means heating oil,
cars, building materials,
salt for the roads,
intermodal containers
filled with food, clothing,
electronics.
That's just the
tip of the iceberg.
The port of Boston
contributes $4.6
million-- billion dollars--
I'm sorry, with a B--
a year to the economy.
11.6 million metric tons of
cargo arrive here by ship.
More than 100 cruise ships
called at the sea port
last year.
We're supposed to get
150 in the coming year.
And 5,000 commuters crisscross
Massachusetts Bay each day
on ferries.
24/7, the Coast
Guard's monitoring,
regulating, and enforcing
safety and security requirements
aboard all foreign and
domestic commercial ships,
including fishing
vessels that bring
in seafood into our state, with
a value second only to Alaska.
So that's your
context on the Coast
Guard for tonight's discussion.
We're here to focus exclusively
on two of the Coast Guard's
maritime missions.
The first, and perhaps our
most famous, search and rescue,
has deep roots in the
treacherous waters
of New England.
The second, marine
environmental response
and prevention and
protection is a high priority
in New England's pristine
and productive waters
both for marine
life and recreation.
I'm happy now to introduce
my colleague, Commander Lee
Titus, who is a
chief of response
operations at the Sector, what
we call the Sector, in Boston.
And that means both
search and rescue
and marine
environmental response.
And he's also our search and
rescue mission coordinator
for the Coast Guard in
Boston, Commander Titus.
- Thank you, Captain,
and good evening.
Again, I'm Commander Lee
Titus, Chief of Response
to US Coast Guard
here in Boston.
As we said, working
for Captain Gelzer,
I'm responsible for coordinating
all maritime law enforcement,
security, environmental
response, again, oil spill,
and search and rescue operation
from New Hampshire to Plymouth.
While the Coast Guard
has 11 official missions,
search and rescue
remains the primary.
Probably nowhere else
in the Coast Guard
is this SAR legacy more
firmly rooted than right
here in Massachusetts, with
the first Revenue Cutter, built
in Newburyport, just
north of here in 1791
and the birthplace of Joshua
James, our most iconic
lifesaver, just down
the road in Hull.
For me personally,
search and rescue
has always been near
and dear and has
consumed the majority of
my professional career
over the past 16 years.
In that time I've
had the opportunity,
or I suppose the misfortune,
to experience search and rescue
from the execution side while
at command of cutters at sea,
and also from the planning
side, in rescue coordination
centers in Seattle,
in Boston, and now I'm
the SAR Mission Coordinator
here in Massachusetts.
Now before I begin to
discuss our SAR work,
as we try to save
us from the ocean,
I'll say up front that the
case that I plan to present
was only the search
and regrettably
never ended in a rescue.
But I hope it will illustrate
the complexity of how
we respond to distress
in the deep ocean.
Even over my short career,
advances in technology
have made boating many times
safer for the general public.
Electronics that
were only in reach
of the military or commercial
vessels 15 years ago,
such as advanced navigation
systems, radar, real time
weather reporting, satellite
communications and survival
equipment are now commonplace
on most oceangoing
recreational boats.
For example, emergency position
indicating radio beacons
or EPIRBs, as most people know
of them, now are $300 to $500
and fit in the back
pocket at times.
Advanced boatbuilding
materials and techniques
have also greatly enhanced the
durability and seaworthiness
of the vessels.
But every year around the
world, hundreds of vessels
are lost at sea often taking
thousands of crew members
to the bottom.
For some perspective, just
within the nation in 2015,
the Coast Guard responded to
over 16,000 search and rescue
cases, saving 3,536 lives.
Here within our area
of responsibility,
we responded to 373 cases
with 88 lives saved.
I don't offer these
stats to tout our work,
but rather to show
that we will never
be ahead of this SAR mission.
And it's hard to
understand or even
try to explain what
drives SAR cases.
But from my experience,
most cases almost always
are a result of dynamic
marine conditions
or equipment
malfunctions or failures
that are then compounded
by sea and heavy weather.
Also and probably the most
prevalent reasons for distress,
are that many boaters
simply underestimate
the power of the sea
or overestimate their
or their vessel's capabilities.
But I'll say, if you must
get into trouble at sea,
I ask you to please do so
within the coastal region,
within Captain's region
here, out about 20
to 30 nautical miles.
And there are plenty of
people getting into distress
within the zone each year.
However, within
this coastal area,
I can dispatch multiple ships
and boats, helicopters, planes
to arrive with under an
hour to the distress.
Additionally, our VHF
radio communications
are highly effective
in the region,
often providing
near instantaneous
location of the distress.
But I ask you-- what if the
distress call comes from here,
1,100 nautical miles at sea?
This falls within our
larger district boundary,
running from the Canadian
border to Northern New Jersey
and out to sea,
1,300 nautical miles.
Following is a case that I
coordinated with my District
Command Center
team back in 2013,
which highlights the
complexity of offshore searches
and will allow me to show
some of the tools we rely on
for planning and execution.
On May 4th, 2013, the 40 foot
sailing vessel Cheeki Rafiki
departed Antigua en
route to the Azores
with a crew of four
men aged 25 to 50.
Two of the crew were highly
experienced in ocean crossings.
And I'll show you,
this is a typical route
there on the right.
And notably, not a straight
line to the Azores,
but rather well north
to just below the ice
fields, but where
they're able to pick up
westerly consistent winds.
Similar routes have
been used really
since Columbus began
sailing here and back.
Now for the first 10 days, the
trip was relatively uneventful,
until they began to
enter a late season storm
system on the 14th.
You can see the relatively
rapid track north of the Cheeki
Rafiki, then the
slower advances as they
shift to the east, the red dots
there, on the 14th and 15th,
and began to encounter
a massive weather system
with increasing winds and seas.
And even if you're not familiar
with offshore weather maps,
one can innately
understand that this is
a bad situation for the vessel.
Late Thursday evening, 15 May,
Boston Rescue Coordination
Center received
an initial report
from the coordination
center in England,
that they had a
report of a sailing
vessel taking on some water.
But they were
keeping up with it,
and were not
requesting assistance.
Four hours later, early
morning on Friday England
passed an email from
the sailing vessel
stating that the
flooding was worse.
And they were unsure
of the source.
We immediately tried
their satellite phone
with no response.
And then launched a C-130
long range rescue aircraft
from Elizabeth City,
North Carolina,
which had about a five hour
estimated time of arrival
to 1100 nautical miles at sea.
Minutes later,
our command center
received the first personal
locator beacon or appeal being
transmitted via satellite.
That's like the EPIRB,
but a manual one.
Within, the command
center received
the visual icon and
position of the PLB
that had been activated.
Much like what you
would think, it
comes up on the screen with
an alarming, horrible alarm
as well.
Unlike an emergency
position indicating
beacon that is
installed in vessel
which automatically deploys, a
PLB must be manually activated.
And that's key.
A second PLB began transmitting
several hours after the first.
Notably the sailing
vessel's larger EPIRB
was never deployed.
Distance and time to the scene
of our fixed wing air asset
was about four to six hours
through the whole search,
leaving only about three to
four hours of search time.
Also unlike our
helicopter assets,
fixed wing aircraft have limited
direct rescue capabilities.
They can drop a life
raft, radios, then
must wait for a surface
vessel to arrive.
In the deep ocean, we often rely
on a system of cargo vessels
that are willing to divert and
assist mariners in distress.
Most vessels are often 10 to 15
or more hours from the scene,
and often must
wait for conditions
to improve to effect rescue.
Mid-morning on Friday,
the C-130 arrived on scene
and reported 15 to 20 foot
seas, 50 knot winds or 60 miles
per hour, which is just
below the hurricane force.
Water temps were reading
55 and air temp was 50.
I'd say at sea,
the Cheeki Rafiki
would have been
completely lost from view
in the trough of the
waves, except for the mast.
For someone in the water,
the wind and sea noise
would have been deafening.
The tops of the waves would
be torn in sheets by the wind,
and the person would
struggle to keep
from drowning from the force
of the sea spray alone.
Now I know when I first
started my career running cases
at sea on the patrol boats,
I had a misguided idea
that just about
anything incongruent
from the vast blue sea would
immediately be seen and pop out
to searchers.
I soon realized how wrong I was.
And when I flip
to the next slide,
I would like the first person
that sees and identifies
the object the Coast Guard and
Navy boats are searching for
to raise their hand.
You have an advantage
in the front.
Any guesses?
- Mid right?
- Let's see what we have here.
The Coast Guard actually knew
the vessel was there and were
just preparing to board.
I like to think that the Navy
may still have been looking.
Now granted, these men were
trying to evade and hide.
But this was a 35 foot go fast,
with four men, fuel barrels,
a 1,000 kilograms of cocaine.
And I ask you, how
difficult do you
think it would be to spot a
person in the water in 20 foot
waves and 50 knot winds?
How about if just the
head of the survivor
were above the water?
So again, our first search
assets arrived on scene.
Nothing was located.
Multiple locator beacon
hits in the area,
but no signs of survivors.
And we began to saturate the
area with both air and surface
assets.
The yellow icons represent
separate signals and position
reports received from the
first and then the second PLB,
the locator beacon, over
the first day of searching.
The series of black triangles
are the fixed search patterns
the aircraft used to quickly
scan the area upon arrival.
As noted, we had lost
already five hours just
getting to the scene.
But in those harsh
conditions, we
were working fast against the
survivability clock for someone
in the water, or
even in a life raft.
Getting an accurate
estimate of survivability
is absolutely essential
in our planning
and eventually when
we may need to be
forced to call off a search.
Since the end of World
War II, the Coast Guard
has continually refined and
adapted cold water models
and currently we
use a probability
of survival decision
or PSDA model, which
is a cold water and
immersion survival
calculator which predicts
heat loss and dehydration.
Two key core temperature
points are calculated.
First is functional
at 93 degrees
Fahrenheit, then survival
at 82 degrees Fahrenheit.
The functional
point is critical,
as it basically means that
someone could self-rescue
and most importantly,
actively keep their face out
of the water.
The PSD model is based on
extensive Canadian and US
military cold water
immersion experiments.
And yes, the military
has immersed thousands
of volunteers as well as from
survival de-brief data starting
with sailors and pilots
from World War I.
It's important to note that
this model is based primarily
on empirical data, while
cold water survival
depends on hundreds of
environmental and physiological
variables.
For example, scientists
simply cannot quantify a will
to survive.
That said, in the end, the body
can only retain heat so long
and the physics of
cold water immersion
will eventually take over.
To give you an idea of
the relentless physics
of cold water immersion,
I want to show you
an example of how this
works, even close to shore.
And John, it's good to know
that you're a kayaker as well.
So I've asked the model to
simulate an average middle age
male in relatively benign
late winter weather.
46 degree air temperature
may seem brisk right now,
but after a long hard
New England winter,
this is almost balmy.
And we see kayakers hit the
water in these late winter,
early spring conditions.
So this gentleman
rolled over one mile
from shore, with no life jacket.
In under two hours,
the man would no longer
be able to actively keep
his head out of the water.
And in seven hours,
he would be dead.
The physics are
unrelenting and brutal.
For the crew of four
on the sailing vessel,
we conservatively
calculated that they
would have all made
it into the life raft,
and they would reach
the functional point
at 16 hours and survival at 20.
Remember, it took us six hours
for the first asset to arrive.
For our calculations,
we use the air temp
as I mentioned 50, and water
temp of 55, windspeed of 50,
and an average victim,
much like our kayaker.
Immersed in water to the
waist-- now this immersion
is designed to simulate being
in a raft in heavy weather
conditions, where it's
impossible to keep
the raft clear of water and they
would be immersed to the waist
during the rough water.
According to our
calculations, the crew
reached functional time
on Saturday around 4:00
in the afternoon, then
survival around 8:00 PM.
And this is really where the
arts and science of search
and rescue planning begins.
The art of search planning
relates to the assumptions.
We are often forced to make
hundreds, if not thousands,
of assumptions over a case,
because we simply never
have all of the facts of
the boat, the scenario,
or the crew.
In this case, no
vessel was sighted.
They must be in the
water or in the raft.
Did they stay with the vessel?
Were they separated?
Did they even make it out alive?
We simply did not know.
Not to diminish
the important work
you mentioned of
our counterparts
running land searches
because they are not easy.
But on land, there
are certain constants.
Meaning there's an average
distance that can be
walked generally in an hour.
Or victims generally
head down hill,
they then follow
water, et cetera.
At sea, environmental
weather factors
can change by the minute.
Currents can run with or
opposed to prevailing winds.
Most importantly, every
boat or object in the water
drifts uniquely based on shape
and its gear configuration.
Finally, each of these
uniquely drifting objects
are subject to
divergence, which means,
depending on the angle of the
object to the seas and winds,
it can drift along
two vectors which
can offset up to 90 degrees.
For years, search planners
relied on static drift data
from a few objects
and observed weather
to calculate the possible drift.
And we certainly located
many people in those years.
I began my career
drawing the drift factors
on vectors on paper charts.
But now thinking back, there
was a lot more art of SAR
I think involved
in those searches.
As of the late '90s, Coast
Guard began developing and using
complex computer modeling
programs that calculate drift
based on historical current
and predicted weather,
with pre-determined, detailed
drift characteristics
on multiple objects.
Currently US Coast Guard uses
the latest generation modeling
called Search and Rescue Optimal
Planning System or SAR OPS.
This system pulls
highly accurate wind
and current conditions from
Navy and NOAA weather databases.
Then uses the data to
theoretically drift
5,000 objects in the water
to establish the most
probable areas to search.
Just please excuse
the simplicity
of the following analogy.
But it's how the program was
originally described to me.
Imagine releasing 5,000
rubber ducks all set
with the mathematical
characteristics of a 40 foot
sailing vessel, life raft
or someone in the water,
and see how they move over time.
Now this dull shot, and
it is horribly dull,
shows a point off of
Cape Ann near Gloucester
in which I had the system drop
2,500 particles with the drift
characteristics of
a life raft and 25
designed to drift like
a person in the water.
So this same 5,000 particles
drifted over 12 hours, 20 knot
winds, and moderate seas.
You'll see that the pink number
ones-- the pink number ones are
the life raft particles,
and the brown number twos
are drifting like a
person in the water.
This looked fairly
compact, I know.
But in 12 hours,
the search area has
stretched to almost 20
miles by 10 miles wide,
200 square nautical miles.
Time is not just against
us in surviving cold water,
but also area to cover.
As we return back to the
case, during the first three
critical days-- remember
the survival clock--
we called in a C-130 aircraft
from Canada, Elizabeth City,
North Carolina, all the way
from Air Force in Georgia,
refueling on the way.
More than 10 commercial
and private vessels
crisscross the area.
The weather improved and
we saturated the area,
searching more than 4,200
square nautical miles of ocean.
The colored blocks
are representing
the drifted particles
instead of the ones and twos,
with the black lines
depicting the various surface
and air search patterns
for those first three days
that we saturated.
On Sunday, a vessel
spotted the overturned haul
in the search area.
We continued to search initially
until early Monday morning then
initially called off the
search almost 30 hours
beyond survival, or as we say
suspended active searching
or access.
Then with considerable
cross-Atlantic governmental
pressure, we reopened
the search on Tuesday,
then continued to search
for another four days,
calling on air assets from
England, the Azores, US
and Canada, as well as
multiple Coast Guard and Navy
ships and helicopters
to finally search
more than 25,000 square
miles spread over 225 miles.
As we were completing our
final searches on Friday,
seven days into the search
before recommending calling off
the search a second time,
a Navy ship and helicopter
relocated the hull
in the drifted area.
We were in luck that there
was a giant circular current
in the middle of the Atlantic.
The life raft-- we
sent a diver down.
The life raft was confirmed to
be still stowed on the boat.
All four sailors were
presumed lost at sea.
We will simply
never know for sure
what happened in the
last several hours
before we lost contact
with the vessel.
But the keel had been
torn from the hull.
And this is my opinion, I
believe the flooding was coming
from damaged bolts
holding the keel on,
once the keel broke
free, the vessel
would have violently rolled
multiple times within minutes.
Some of the crew may have
been thrown overboard.
We mentioned the PLBs being
activated, while some of them
may never have made
it out of the cabin.
The accident was dynamic,
rapid with almost no time
to react or prepare.
The case was tragic and like
all the unresolved cases
in my career, still
haunts me to this day.
But during the week
before and then
two weeks after this accident,
several strong, unexpected, low
pressure systems ripped
through the same transit zone,
and we successfully
located and rescued crews
from three other sailboats
in the same region.
I don't understand what caused
the series of late season
weather systems to
push through that year.
But as the sea temperatures
rise and currents shift,
the weather patterns
and sea routes
that sailors have relied
on for hundreds of years
will also change.
And already we see, as sea
ice recedes further north,
some cross-Atlantic
vessels are pushing
north into colder waters
with more consistent wind,
but of course, farther and
farther from rescue assets.
I do know, however,
that as mariners adapt,
we too will continue to work
to save them from our oceans.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- All right.
It's easy for me.
He is one of my-- best part
of my team there in Boston.
And I thought that
was really well done.
I know I shouldn't say that.
But I only will say
that, for anyone here who
is venturing out
into the water, you
should know that this is the guy
that is managing that search.
And he's the guy who takes the
calls at 3:00 in the morning
and really doesn't
rest until we have
found somebody and hopefully
brought them home safely.
And he made it very clear,
we're going to shift gears now.
The ocean is a dangerous
place for people.
And that case is a really
good example of that.
But I believe that it is
equally vulnerable from man.
And for thousands
of years, people
have used the ocean as a
medium for transportation
and the movement of
critical commodities.
Billions and billions
of gallons of oil
are transported by
sea via tankship.
And while sea transportation
remains by far the safest
mode over truck,
pipeline, and rail, when
spills occur in the ocean the
consequences are very high.
So today I'll talk
about the system
we've developed to protect
the ocean from people,
and specifically the
challenging scenario
when oil spills at sea.
So I like to start
with this photo
when I'm explaining the purpose
and the goal of the Coast
Guard's marine
environmental protection
mission and our national
contingency plan for spills.
He's a little
alarming, isn't he?
It's a very young pelican,
four weeks old to be exact.
And I use this very photo
to try and inspire my team,
during the Coast
Guard's response
to the largest marine oil spill
in history, Deepwater Horizon.
I had never seen a
baby brown pelican
before I was deployed
to Venice, Louisiana,
for that entire summer
beginning in the spring of 2010.
I had actually never
been really to the Gulf.
And that spill, of
course, was the result
of the catastrophic explosion
and loss of the drill
rig named Deepwater Horizon.
And we should never talk
about this epic oil spill
without mentioning first the
tragic loss of 11 drill workers
who were killed that day.
Most Coast Guard
cases include several
of our maritime missions
that bleed into one another
during a large scale response.
That event began with a
desperate mayday call,
and an immense search
and rescue response
that I won't talk about today.
But it ultimately morphed into
a massive oil spill response
and accident investigation.
And all, simultaneously,
these were
responsibilities and
priorities for the Coast Guard.
It was estimated that more
than 200 million gallons of oil
spilled before BP was able to
cap the well after 87 days.
It was an operation unlike
any we had ever seen.
Back to our baby
pelican on his nest
in the mangroves
of Breton Island
off the coast of Louisiana.
I remember tacking this
photo up in the command post,
and it prompted my
operations section
chief to walk over and say,
that's one ugly bird, ma'am.
It looks like pteradactyl
ghost from Scooby Doo.
But if that's what we're here
to protect, then I'm on it.
You see Coasties are life savers
by nature, even when we're
talking about pelican lives.
Our mission that summer
was sobering-- to protect
Plaquemines Parish, the
closest point of land
to the oil spill 40 miles away.
It's home to the Delta
National Wildlife Refuge.
Plaquemines is comprised
of 40,000 acres
of highly sensitive marsh, home
to countless species of fish,
waterfowl, marine
reptiles, and mammals
and nursery for their offspring.
I was Incident
Commander for that area,
with a team of 800 responders
including 150 Coast Guard
Members.
The stakes were very high.
One of our many marine
environmentally sensitive
areas, amidst that entire
sensitive marshland,
was Breton Island, home
to this pelican chick
who was born after the spill
as the oil was spreading out
across the water and
threatening the island.
It was our job to
protect him and thousands
of pelicans and
other bird species
that made that precious
habitat their home.
So I'm going to come back
to him a little bit later.
The Deepwater Horizon oil spill
was unique in many respects,
including the source of the
spill from an offshore rig.
We were used to ships
being the source of spill.
The challenge in
securing that source--
it's always our first
priority, secure the source.
We could not secure the source,
an unimaginable volume of oil
from a well with a seemingly
unlimited capacity.
The timing of the
spill was particularly
problematic in regard
to wildlife impacts,
during the vibrant spring
season in the Gulf.
It was hard from every
perspective-- scientifically,
politically, and psychologically
to the people of the Gulf,
who had suffered greatly
from Hurricane Katrina.
However, this catastrophe
showed that the nation's system
of preparing for and
responding to oil spills
is ultimately sound, even under
the most extreme circumstances.
And it's designed to optimize
the devastating impacts
of any spill.
That's not to say there weren't
lasting impacts of this spill
or any oil spill
for that matter.
Once oil spills into the water,
we are in a losing proposition,
so I won't sugarcoat it.
Just one example,
Audubon estimates
that a million
coastal birds died
as a result of the
Deepwater Horizon spill.
There were many, many
other catastrophic effects.
That's just one.
Prevention is the only true
answer to an oil spill.
And this is one in which the
Coast Guard is highly invested
in intensive regulation
of the shipping
industry and its safety.
But as long as oil is
our primary energy source
and human factors exist,
accidents will happen
and even if less
frequently, oil will spill.
Without the system
in place to respond
to spills that has existed
for the past 25 years,
I submit that the outcome
would have been a lot worse.
Deepwater Horizon drew a
grand total of 47,000 federal,
state, and local responders,
including 68 Coast Guard
personnel and dozens of Coast
Guard aircraft and cutters,
and many other agency aircraft
and National Guardsmen.
Across the five Gulf
states that were impacted,
responders recovered
35 million gallons
of oil, millions of
pounds of oil debris
from 900 miles of
beach, and deployed
2,000 miles of containment boom
to protect sensitive habitat.
The spill redefined every
measure of our nation's
response capability.
And yet its impact on
our national system
was not as profound as
a much smaller spill,
still groundbreaking, that
had occurred 20 years before.
And many of you know this,
the Exxon Valdez in 1989
at the very beginning of
my Coast Guard career.
Although 20 times
smaller than Deepwater,
it insured the creation
of a system that
was absolutely critical to
managing the massive Gulf Coast
disaster.
To fully grasp the
Coast Guard's efforts
to protect the ocean
from oil spills and man,
you have to understand the
significance of the Exxon
Valdez event.
After running
aground on Bligh Reef
and spilling 11 million
gallons of heavy crude
into Alaska's pristine
Prince William Sound in 1989,
a slow and challenged
response was the catalyst
for creating stricter
and a systematic approach
to environmental disasters.
For the nation and
the Coast Guard,
it served as a basis for the
emergence of a stronger regime
to drastically improve
the shipment of oil
and the way oil spills are
handled both on the water
and in the courtroom.
18 months after the
event, in August of 1990,
Congress amended
the Clean Water Act
by passing the Oil
Pollution Act of 1990.
This changed the
way we did business,
creating a comprehensive
prevention, response,
liability, and
compensation regime
to deal with spills from
ships and facilities
into the navigable US waters.
The Oil Pollution Act
brought significant advances,
such as setting new requirements
for vessel construction, crew
licensing, and manning.
Most notably, it
mandated double hulls
for oil tank ships,
a second wall
with a buffer encapsulating
the cargo to prevent damage
from collision or grounding.
The latest-- I'm sorry,
the last single hull ship
were phased out of
operation just last year,
25 years after the
milestone spill.
The law significantly broadened
financial responsibility
requirements.
It specified that the
spiller would pay.
It seems obvious, right?
Now companies would
be required to pay
for cleanup and
compensation, all
liable for costs and damages.
It imposed stiffer civil
and criminal penalties,
and even jail time
for certain spills.
The regulations tightened
the authority of the federal
on scene coordinator to oversee
spill response and preparedness
activities at the local level.
The Coast Guard is the
federal on scene coordinator
in the coastal zone, the
EPA in the inland zone.
This approach in and of itself
was well ahead of its time
and remains a model
for integrating
all involved parties into
the response organization.
As federal on scene
coordinator, the Coast Guard
acts as that honest
broker, bringing together
all the stakeholders
with different skill sets
to solve this
unsolvable problem.
And this happens
before the spill,
which is critical during
the preparedness piece.
This ensures a viable plan
for oil spill response.
That includes frequent
exercises to enhance readiness
for a spill.
In each port, the Coast
Guard shares something
called the area committee.
The co-chair comes
from the state,
in this case the Mass
Environmental Department.
Committee members
include federal, state,
and local environmental
agencies, and importantly,
the maritime industry is on
the hot seat, particularly
oil companies and transporters.
It also includes non-government
organizations, nonprofits,
scientists from academia
and from industry,
as well as tribal reps
that all come to the table
to plan ahead for a spill.
If a spill actually
occurs, these players
come together, but now with
some familiarity, and a plan.
The Coast Guard, the state,
and the responsible party
form a unified
command in the event
of a spill, where
the Coast Guard holds
51% of the vote on
response decisions.
But it takes full advantage of
the spiller's typically vast
resources to resolve the issue.
They write the checks.
Again, oil spills
are messy events.
But there is a way to
optimize the outcome
and best mitigate
environmental damage.
If we get to that
point, we are positioned
to do that, having
prepared in advance
and educated the industry
on the expectation
for an aggressive response.
As a rule, most members
of the Coast Guard
do not have extensive training
in the science of oil spills.
What we do have is military
training-- training
to lead in crisis, training
to bring order to chaos.
As the federal on
scene coordinator,
I don't have to be the
smartest person in the room,
and that's lucky for all of you.
What I do need to do is know
how to find the smartest person
and bring them to the table.
And we have a good
track record of bringing
similar and disparate groups
together and drawing out
the most positive solutions.
It's not about command control.
You do need command control when
you're doing law enforcement
or when you're conducting
military operations.
But it doesn't works for
environmental response.
There we work to build
trust and consensus,
to break down stovepipes
and parochialisms,
to maintain the big picture.
The Coast Guard
has a similar role
facilitating research
and development efforts
across the interagency
for oil spills response,
again not being a scientist.
We have a voice as well in
the international regime,
bringing together
and cultivating
mature relationships
via long agreements
that we've had to coordinate
planning, training exercises,
and spill response
with our neighbors
to the north in
Canada and in Mexico.
And now, a big focus with
Russia in the Arctic,
because of all the oil moving
through the very sensitive
Arctic, and in the Caribbean
and with the Panama Canal
authority.
All of these
efforts are integral
to a marine environmental
protection program and process
that combines proactive
planning, disciplined
exercising, and
collaborative response
as well as rigorous study and
resolution of lessons learned.
We try to take every
spill and learn
from where we made mistakes.
And the greatest
challenge is to balance
all of that and the work
to protect the environment
with balance of the
facilitation of commerce,
which is absolutely something
we have to do in this country.
The marine transportation
system is the lifeblood
of our national economy.
More than 2 billion gallons of
oil and liquified natural gas
come by ship into the
port of Boston every year.
Those tank ships transit
across Stellwagen Bank, an 800
plus square mile marine
sanctuary and feeding grounds
for whales just 25
miles east of Boston.
All the jet fuel for Logan
Airport comes right into Boston
through its very rigid
navigable channels
and delivered to Sunoco on
the very narrow Chelsea Creek.
Oil spills remain
a daily threat,
but our prevention and
preparedness efforts
have reduced the
risk considerably.
We continue to work together,
the public and private sectors
and academia.
Partnerships are paramount.
Through these efforts,
we've seen a marked decrease
in the annual number of spills.
We have less than a third of the
number of spills we experienced
in the mid-'90s, and spill
quantities have dropped
considerably, with the exception
of a few really big ones.
From the early '90s
to present, an average
of three gallons
of oil were spilled
for every 1 million
gallons of oil transported.
Fewer spills means
fewer opportunities
to train and refine our response
practices during actual spills.
So that's a downside,
but those are
good tradeoffs in my opinion.
So that makes exercising
even more important than ever
to keep sharp and ready.
This past summer, we held
one of our area committee
meetings and a tabletop
exercise to test
our response to a spill
in Stellwagen Bank
during the whale season.
It's unthinkable.
It raised innumerable
concerns and conversations
about tradeoffs that
we continue to tackle.
We must continuously
question our techniques
to push for continued
improvements in R&D for spill
response technologies
and to unfailingly
invest in partnerships.
Our goal is to ensure we retain
the expertise to prevent,
prepare for, and
respond when necessary,
so we can recover from future
incidents in an increasingly
complex national and global
operating environment.
So let's return to the pelican
chicks on Black Breton Island.
In our command post,
around the table
I had every federal
agency that might
have a stake in the spill--
EPA, US Fish and Wildlife,
the National Guard.
I had the parish
representatives.
I had the State of Louisiana.
Everyone's around the table.
Everyone's raising their issues.
The representative from
US Fish and Wildlife
was responsible for the island
and the National Wildlife
Refuge.
As incident
commander, he asked me
to prioritize the island
and its protection,
as it was anticipated that
oil would be washing ashore
in the coming days during these
absolutely critical point.
And there were frankly
too many priorities
to balance, but his
voice at the table
and what was at stake compelled
us to redouble our efforts.
With three layers of containment
boom and near 24 hour
monitoring due to the
dynamic environment there,
we did just that.
And while there were reports
of pelicans on the island that
had been oiled, it
was actually limited
to those that had
flown off shore to feed
and had returned contaminated.
Because of our
collective efforts,
oil did not reach the shores
of Breton Island or the pelican
nests in a detrimental way.
In the bottom photo you
can see just how many
birds inhabit this island.
I mean that's just
one stretch of it.
There are pelicans,
sandwich terns, gulls.
If birds freak you out, this
is not where you want to be.
But it was absolutely
fascinating.
And in the background, you can
barely see this black stretch
is our oil containment
boom, one layer of it.
It was a very large
Navy boom that
was part of our tiered
protection system.
So that summer, the Fish
and Wildlife Service
had planned to cancel the annual
banding of juvenile pelicans,
fearing the added stress
on top of the spill
would be catastrophic
to the colony.
But because the island
remained protected in the end,
they were able to reschedule
the banding, which
would prove critical and
provide data in the coming years
that they absolutely needed.
I got the unique chance to
step out of the command post
and assist in banding.
And it was a prime
opportunity to reflect
on the reason we were there.
My partner from
Fish and Wildlife
invited me to come along and
it changed my perspective
inordinately.
There were many failures
during the spill,
volumes of lessons learned
from our response efforts.
But we did enjoy
some small successes.
Despite the heavy wildlife
losses since that time,
Fish and Wildlife
report some good news
regarding breeding
birds on Breton Island.
The number of colonial nesting
seabirds nesting on the island
has generally increased.
In the year following the spill,
over 8,500 brown pelican nests
and over 120,000 tern
nests were documented
on the refuge, which represents
the largest number of pelican
nests recorded since Hurricane
Katrina, and the largest number
of tern nests in over a decade.
This is just a small
example of how much
we have at stake in protecting
our oceans from people.
The Coast Guard will remain
committed and focused
on this important mission
and priority for our nation.
Thank you for being here today.
It represents the
commitment that you
show for protecting our oceans.
And we would love to answer any
questions that you have now.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you, Claudia
and Captain Gelzer
and Commander Titus.
So we have a microphone here.
We're actually
recording this live.
So if you have a
question, raise your hand,
and we'll pass around
the microphone.
Actually I have,
OK, here's one here.
Let me ask one question
first, since I get
the prerogative of doing that.
So I understand the
SAR models for drift.
But I was kind of curious for
the oil spill-- predicting
where the oil might go
and spread-- are there
any models for this?
- Yeah, we're fortunate.
The Coast Guard
has a relationship
with NOAA, the National
Oceanographic and Atmospheric
Administration.
And every Coast Guard
area, every district,
like Lee explained,
from Maine to New York
has a NOAA scientific
support coordinator
that is assigned to us,
because we're not scientists,
as our science adviser.
And NOAA has highly
sophisticated models that they
run on spill trajectories.
And we've had great success
trying to anticipate
where things are going to go.
- OK, so as a
follow up question,
this is partly because
of the course I teach.
I teach my students
about ocean currents.
And so there are a
lot of simulations
and actually tracking data.
So I see the Atlantic
currents, there's
like a loop that goes
through the Gulf Stream.
Or that goes through the Gulf
and then out around Florida.
Was there a thought or a concern
that there was a possibility
that the Deepwater Horizon
oil might have gotten
caught in one of those vortices?
- That was a huge concern.
And we had, at the
national level,
we had all the agencies
sit around the table
and the National
Response Team, which
is made up of all the federal
agencies with a stake.
And NOAA is a big voice on that.
And that concern of
catching in a loop current.
They anticipated that it could
go up as far as North Carolina
and beyond.
And so they kept
watching that, and they
had a plan for how to mitigate.
But it didn't end up doing that.
- No, good.
So we have a question over here.
- Great, thank you.
A compliment and a question,
or a thanks and a question.
My wife and I actually
traveled down to the Gulf
during the spill as
part of a task force
from the New England Aquarium,
observing what was going on.
And we were on Grand Isle.
I just have to say
that what we observed
in terms of the efforts on
the part of the people there
and the cleanup coordinated
by you was really tremendous.
It was like a war zone.
And an amazing amount of
work was getting done.
So thank you for
your efforts on that.
- Do you think you could write
a letter to Anderson Cooper?
- I'm happy to write
a letter to whoever
you think ought to get one.
Secondly, I'm worried
about the Arctic.
And I wonder what sort
of international rapid--
because you know, it's a
complicated sovereignty issue--
what kind of rapid
response assets
are in place for a spill.
And I understand the Coast Guard
is somewhat shy on icebreakers.
Could you comment?
- Sure.
And we are.
We have one ice
breaker, and we are
hoping to have more
in the coming decade.
But there's been
a tremendous focus
on planning for
Arctic spill response.
And as you know, there
have been efforts and hopes
and plans to drill
in the Arctic.
And having worked at our
national level program,
I'm here to tell
you that responding
to a spill in the Arctic is
like responding on the moon.
And it is really the tyranny of
the distance and the weather,
the dynamic weather, and
the cold water temperatures.
And that is not to say
that we are not continually
looking and working on
research and development
and working with our partner
agencies and the Bureau
of Safety and Environmental
Enforcement, which
looks at whether or not to
issue the permits to drill.
We've done a number
of exercises,
bringing together the
Alaskan government.
And we are working with
other Arctic nations
on these really tough questions.
And there are plans in place.
And we really look
to the industry
to provide the
response capability.
And if they want
to be able to do it
and they get the
permission to do it,
then the onus is on them.
But so much of
the infrastructure
doesn't even exist, to
bring the materials in
or to bring the people
and the responders in.
So tons of tough
questions on that.
And you know it's
really something
to keep a close eye on
and to watch and monitor.
And I think it's one of those
very, very, very tough things.
Because responding to an
oil spill under the best
of conditions is really hard.
So we continue to
grapple with that.
And we work very hard
on the prevention piece
and making sure that we're
doing these inspections
and making sure ships are safe.
And so that's really what
we're very, very much
focused on and continue to
work on the other piece.
But there's a lot of study
and good work going on.
Thank you.
- Chris?
- Hi, thank you for those
very nice presentations.
My question is how much
drones, unmanned drones may be
changing your own operations?
Are they, you know, likely to
be game changers in the way
that you do things, or
are they just not going
to be very useful in
the kinds of weather
that you often
have to deal with?
- Well, I think they actually
would be very useful just
to be able to have
consistent presence watching
both from environmental response
as well as search and rescue.
It's really the
issue of time that we
can stay on scene
maintaining communications,
maintaining visibility.
To be completely
honest, at this point
we are not allowed to
use unmanned aircraft.
It's a regulatory issue at
this point for the government.
So I hope that--
- And that's something I think
the Coast Guard is working on,
to try to get through that.
Because this is technology
that we should be fully taking
advantage of.
And from the oil
spill response part,
on the ice breaker that we
have that we put scientists
on going up in the Arctic,
they are experimenting
with the use of drones and
for our spill response, which
would be phenomenal considering
the risks of putting aircraft
up in that environment.
So there's certainly
some testing going on.
And I know the industry is
also putting a lot of emphasis
on those capabilities.
- Actually, it's
sort of related.
I'm really curious
about sort of some
of your favorite interesting
research projects.
Whether that's with groups
around here or in Woods Hole.
Do you have any sort
of favorite ones
that you want to highlight?
- In regard to search
and rescue or--
- Sort of anything.
I have no idea what the Coast
Guard does research into.
More along the
lines of sort of I
guess very low level
basic research.
Do you know what I mean?
- So one that I would say
I think is we have a number
of partnerships with partner
agencies who also have a stake
in spill response--
EPA and BSEE.
And BSEE manages a burn
pan down in Alabama
that we're working
to test you know
how to more effectively burn
oil, which has tradeoffs
as well, air tradeoffs.
But that's one big project.
Our R&D center is in
Groton, Connecticut,
and having a two
years out of the job
where I was really
focused on that.
But it might be that I need
to get back get back to you
on sort of what the latest
and greatest is in terms
of what they're looking at.
But burning oil and obviously
looking really closely
at the impacts of
using dispersants.
- There's one back here
and then one up here.
- This is about rescue.
I'm just curious.
You've pointed out
rescue operations
where people who seem to
know what they're doing
get in trouble.
And on land, with hiking
and mountaineering and stuff
like that, there's just a
lot of very careless stuff--
that the people don't
prepare properly.
They run out in
sneakers and stuff.
And then, the next thing
you know they're in trouble.
But they also risk the
lives of the rescuers.
Can you give us an
idea of proportion?
Do you get a lot of
that stuff on sea?
Do you see what I mean?
It's a little cynical.
- I mean I've got my
thoughts, but you--
- I'll be honest,
it's just so dynamic,
the weather conditions.
And if we just take
our region here.
I mean even on a
beautiful summer day.
I mean it can be
gorgeous all day long.
And then we get a we get
a fast cell come through,
and we have five, six
boats going aground.
Or we have somebody
taking on water,
but the weather's been
perfect all day long.
So I'm not going
to call that person
was due to their inexperience.
I think people just
get caught unaware.
I think that the conditions
overwhelm people so quickly.
Captain, go ahead.
- So that I think
that's very much true
and we've had marine events
where we have big kayak
or stand up paddle races.
And without any warning the
storm system will change
and suddenly we've got
40 people in the water.
And so you know that can happen.
What I think we experience
that I think most people don't
realize is this is
obviously a beautiful area
with wonderful summers and
lots of recreational kayakers
and stand up paddlers
and really what we end up
doing is we end up
looking for everyone
that ends up being a mystery.
If your kayak blows
off of your dock,
and you don't know it-- so
you're just out at the mall--
the Coast Guard is going to look
for you for days potentially.
And so we are always
pushing for-- just realize,
we always assume the worst.
And we have our calculation.
And we will run
our drift models.
And it doesn't matter
what, day time or how long.
And we're going to look
until we get an answer.
And it's hard on the kayaks,
because with boats, small boats
that have hull numbers.
We can figure out
who the owner is.
But if you don't put your
name and number on your kayak,
then there's a lot of
assets and resources
and aircraft and people
risking their lives
to look for somebody
who's not even in trouble.
So that's the only other
thing I'd say about that.
But we do have people who
I think really greatly
underestimate the
power of this area
and how treacherous
the waters are,
and they're just not
necessarily loaded for bear
when they go out there.
- I'd say that's right.
- I'll attest, may
I give a personal?
So in 2003, I was paddling in
Nantucket Sound, sunny skies.
It was October, so
the water temperature
was about 53 degrees.
I did notice it and I put
on a wetsuit to go out.
I was paddling,
about half an hour
later huge fog bank comes in
and basically just blank out,
can't see a darn thing.
I noticed the wind
direction, so I
used that as kind
of a natural compass
and found my way back to shore.
But the next day I went out
paddling and the harbor master
stopped me and asked if I'd
seen two young women in kayaks.
And they had launched
exactly the same time
I'd launched in sunny weather.
They were wearing bathing
suits and t-shirts
in relational kayaks.
They told their
boyfriends they were
going to be back in 10 minutes.
After 45, 50 minutes,
they didn't return.
This was when the
fog was really thick.
And then a massive search
and rescue was triggered.
Everybody with a boat was
out there in the water.
And that day I saw a
Coast Guard helicopter
was going up and
down, presumably
using the drift models to
figure out where to search.
And they found the two
kayaks tied together.
No women.
And then the next day,
they found the body of one
of the young women, never
found the body of the other.
That was a case where, if the
fog hadn't rolled in suddenly,
they probably would
have been just fine.
But not being
dressed for immersion
was clearly a contributory
factor, and the swift change
in conditions.
And so it was basically
sort of two things
that compounded themselves.
So that's my own
personal experience.
And then I went to town with
safety equipment and everything
at that point, because
I escaped with my life.
And you know I wasn't
going to risk it again.
So that's my own
personal anecdote.
We had a question up here.
- You talked about the
fortunately relatively few
incidents you have
to train against.
To what extent are you
using simulation technology.
I mean I certainly
know that aircrews
do, but in a more, in a
larger more macro sense.
- For oil spills?
- Yeah.
- We're limited on what we
can actually put in the water,
if you mean like physically.
We do some simulation.
But at the national
level, they're
really trying to get
permission in certain areas
to actually spill
oil, so that we
can practice responding
to it in the safest
possible environment.
They do this in other countries.
And we really need
to do it in order
to be able to-- in
New Jersey, there's
a really cool oil
spill facility that's
a big pool that's run by BSEE.
And we do a lot
of work with them
to try to figure out which
technologies and skimmers work
the best.
But for small spills,
even locally, we
might simulate just so that
when we're testing industry,
because that's what we do, we
go out to industry and we say,
guess what?
You have an unscheduled drill.
You just spilled 2,100
gallons, Exxon, go.
And so sometimes we'll pour
peat moss or something in there
so they can actually be
chasing something in reality.
But you know we're
somewhat limited on how
we simulate spills.
- What about digital
technologies?
- And I'd say that our NOAA
scientific support coordinator
can help us with that
because they always
do provide these trajectories
about where the oil might go.
And so we definitely take
full advantage of the digital
and the scientific
way of doing it.
- Question right there, yeah.
Can you just pass it over?
Yeah.
- I just had a question
about other contaminants
in the water.
So my specific idea was
maybe fracking contaminants.
And you know that hasn't
really hit the oceans
as far as I know.
It's relatively new.
What are you guys-- are
you planning for that?
Or is that not really
on your radar at all?
- Right, so all of that kind of
change in how we're extracting
oil-- it isn't really impacting
Massachusetts so much.
But a lot of those oils
are being carried by rail.
So even in New York on the
Hudson there's threats.
And there's lots of focus.
And we have really
changed our response plans
to try to ensure that we know--
because those materials they
react a little bit
differently on the water.
And they're a little
higher volatility.
And so that has absolutely
been looked at nationwide
and continues.
We have a continued
challenge there
because we had a lot of rail
accidents there for a while.
And a lot of times
they go over the water.
And so that's
definitely something
we look at and in
fact, it just happens
that right now those
commodities are not
coming through our area.
But some chemicals
are going by rail,
and so we also
look in those areas
where they come over waterways.
And we have chemical response
techniques and procedures
that we're constantly
working on.
But the fracking
oil is something
that we're absolutely focused
on the last three years.
- Do you have time for one
last, well, two last questions.
Two hands up.
So let's go with those.
- This is for Captain Gelzer.
So obviously you
mentioned that prevention
is the best strategy of all.
And you mentioned that we
were successful in going
from single hulled to
double hulled vessels.
But since Deepwater
Horizon, I understand
that before Deepwater
Horizon, there
was a requirement in
many other countries
to provide a relief well.
Have we implemented
mandatory relief wells
in the United States?
- So that again is
the BSEE, the agency
that was Minerals
Management Service that
was split back off
so there wouldn't
be a conflict between
the agency that
sold the leases and the
agency that enforced
the response, that
is an issue, that
is their responsibility
and their issue.
And I think they
are in fact working
on that and in this case
I think, as you know,
they believed that
that was the case.
But it wasn't in fact.
But all of those issues
are being worked.
I mean the Coast
Guard, that is--
we don't have that oversight.
We do inspect the drill rig.
But we don't inspect any of
the under sea and under water,
but BSEE is-- and it's the
Bureau of Ocean Enforcement
Management, BOEM, is the other
part of that split off that are
looking at those issues.
So I mean those are really
important, critical issues.
And they're doing more
exercises and making sure
that they test
those capabilities.
- I was just curious
about how involved
the Coast Guard is with global
climate change, sea level rise?
Is How do you get
involved with that?
And then, what is the
voice that the Coast
Guard has at the federal
level about your concerns?
- [INAUDIBLE] Do
you have an answer?
Yes, so.
- Locally, we won't [INAUDIBLE].
- Right.
And we're at the
local level working
on all sorts of
emergency response plans.
And we are working
with the state
and the local
municipalities to make sure
that we would combine
forces for response
to ocean level
rising, floodings.
You know we're always
in the game on that.
We also have a seat at
the ocean planning table,
but it's more of the coastal
zone management planners
and it falls a little
bit out of our purview.
We don't have the key
voice in that conversation.
We're responders
and we're planners.
But you know we're definitely
at the table and very involved
in any emergency
response-type planning.
But you know there's
big, big issues that
are facing any coastal
area, and certainly Boston
has huge challenges.
- OK, so let's thank the
Captain and Commander again.